[Music]  kim kardashian and kanye west get their  glam on for push a tease wedding we'll  just have to wait and see the 41 year  old rapper tied the knot with longtime  girlfriend Virginia Williams at the  Cavalier Hotel in Virginia Beach and  while mr. West looked dapper for the  occasion rocking a black suit and white  shirt sans tie I love that it's his  reality star wife who shined the  brightest and I got the vintage online  look for pushes wedding in Virginia and  check out her sparkly accessory the  vintage nineties phone purse is part of  Kim favorite collection okay so I just  have to show you guys my favorite new  bags it's not not the curious you know I  collect to deliever bags so the West's  weren't the only famous faces at pushes  wedding Pharrell Williams served as the  rapper's best man of course  Kanye produced pushes newest album  Daytona which dropped back in May  [Music]  [Applause]